The first shot went into arms, I believe,
it was a 90 year old grandmother
in the United Kingdom
on December 8th.
All done?
All done.
And then a week later, a nurse in New York
becomes the first American
person to get vaccinated.
We'd been dealing with the
pandemic for almost a year
at this point, and it really
felt like this kind of
moment where, you know, "Holy crap.
Like, this might actually be the beginning
of the end of that."
And I don't think any of
us realized, at that point,
just how long of a road
it would be from there.
Covid has been resurging even in places
where they thought they
had it nailed down.
This is becoming a pandemic
of the unvaccinated.
It was a desperate situation in India,
rich and poor alike, they
were all equally hit.
There are a lot of mistruths
out there about the vaccines.
You've seen the pictures, all
over the internet of people
who've had these shots and
now they're magnetized.
Most of the vaccines were
booked by the rich nations.
Many of the African
leaders later called it
"vaccine apartheid".
Over the past year, the
world has been engaged
in a massive ethic to end
the Covid-19 pandemic,
but a series of daunting
and unpredictable challenges
have stood in the way.
To understand how far we've
come and where we could go
from here, you have to trace the course
of the vaccination
campaign across the globe,
country by country, city
by city, shot by shot.
This is humanity's first
year of fighting back
against Covid-19.
As the vaccines were becoming available,
we realized that this was going to be
an unprecedented public
health campaign, globally.
Never before have we had a
vaccine that we tried to roll out
simultaneously all across the world,
and we started to realize
that there was not going to be
the kind of data tracking
that everybody would want.
During the pandemic, in
2020, there was very poor
availability of data
tracking the actual cases
of this disease.
Public health organizations
were not doing a sufficient job
of tracking case numbers,
hospitalizations, deaths,
and we realized that nobody
was really setting up
to do that for vaccinations, so we decided
that we needed to step in
and tackle that ourselves.
This is Bloomberg's
Covid-19 Vaccine Tracker,
where we tracked vaccinations
of the largest vaccination
campaign in history.
We put together a team
of people and decided
that we would just start
counting and trying to figure out
where were vaccines going?
At the very beginning,
everybody was basically just
trying to get shots in arms
as fast as possible.
The drug companies that
were making these vaccines,
they had really just begun production.
They hadn't nailed down their
supply process just yet,
and we were really just in this period
of not enough vaccines or even close to it
to meet what the demand was,
and so people were
desperate for this stuff.
Today, we're on the verge
of another American medical miracle.
Together, we will defeat the virus
and we will soon end the pandemic,
and we will save millions
and millions of lives.
Hundreds of thousands of
lives in the United States
and around the world would be saved,
people would still be alive
today if our government
had listened to the
science, had told Americans
the real risk of this virus
and put tools and information
and clear messaging out to
help people save their lives
and protect themselves
from getting this virus.
As the U.S. vaccine rollout ramps up,
major logistical issues start to emerge.
The process the Trump
administration had set up
was sending vaccines to
states and they were sending
kind of an unpredictable number.
It was far short of
what the states wanted.
Governors were screaming, you know,
we were trying to get
the basic information
out of the system, but
there was no tracking system
for vaccines.
And we don't have good tools
for tracking data around Covid generally.
A lot of the data collection
that's done is done by CDC.
CDC's culture is very retrospective.
They're accustomed to doing
these very careful analyses
that are backward looking.
They're based on retrospective data,
so data they collect after the fact.
It's not the kind of
organization that has sort of
a crisis mentality that
you need to put out data,
even if it's not fully baked.
So this is the shared spreadsheet
for Bloomberg's Vaccine
Tracker that we would enter
every day with 175 countries,
all the U.S. states
and Canadian provinces, and the data
was coming from all over all
sorts of different places,
from social media to reporters
hounding government sources,
to, you know, a Lieutenant
governor who wanted to post it
on Twitter every week.
This normally is not
something that journalists
should have to do.
This is data that's normally
tracked by governments
and produced in a kind of uniform way,
but we have never had
a situation like this,
where real-time information
was required to respond
to the pandemic.
As more supply becomes available
in the first weeks of
2021, the U.S. soon hits
an encouraging number.
More doses of vaccine administered
than total coronavirus cases to date.
I remember we crossed
this milestone early on,
and it felt like this
really helpful moment,
and then you realize like, "Oh my God,
there's still so much further to go."
But in other parts of the world,
the vaccination campaign
has barely even started.
Brazil was starting to see a second wave
that started kind of in early mid-December
in the northern city of
Manaus, which turned out
to be one of the great tragedies
of the pandemic in Brazil.
Bolsonaro, our president,
has been consistent
in his approach to the pandemic in that
he has mostly dismissed it.
He does not believe in vaccines.
He just thinks people get better immunity
when they get sick and
recover, and so his government
was very late in buying vaccines.
We had a Senate probe into
the government's handling
of the pandemic this year,
that looked at all the attempts
that were made by Pfizer, for example,
in selling vaccines to
Brazil, and they emailed
and they sent letters, and they offered,
and they called for meetings
and the government would just not respond.
Pressure built on the government,
enough that they had to buy vaccines,
but we took so long to buy the vaccines
that once they decided
to buy, the answer we got
from companies, they
said, "Well, from July on,
I can give you the shots you want,
but I don't have them right now
because I already sold them."
Brazil's limited supply of
vaccines barely makes a dent
in infection rates, allowing
the pandemic to rage on
almost unabated for months.
When it comes to buying
vaccines, you have to rush.
A lot of the countries that waited
ended up having to wait
longer to get the shots.
In terms of vaccination, at the beginning
of the year, there were
no prospects as yet
on supply of the vaccines to
Africa and what was available
was being booked by the rich nations.
So there was a concern
that the poor nations
or low-income nations would not get access
to these vaccines at all.
So Covax was a deliberate initiative
to really ensure that there was access
to the Covid-19 vaccines
equitably among nations.
Covax, founded by the WHO
and other global health
organizations in 2020,
sets an ambitious goal for 2021,
deliver nearly 2 billion vaccine doses
to low-income countries
by the end of the year.
It's so important to try
and get these products
into every country and
every environment to stop
this crisis, save lives
as rapidly as possible.
It's impossible that the
global economy going again,
unless all countries are vaccinating.
It's impossible to protect
against the emergence of variants
if we are only vaccinating
in some parts of the world.
Key to Covax's supply
is a country long-known
as one of the world's
pharmaceutical powerhouses.
India, of course, is known
as the pharmacy to the world
because it produces the vast majority
of the world's vaccines.
In fact, much of that is
located just in one institute,
the Serum Institute of
India on the outskirts
of the city of Mumbai.
The Serum Institute had got
a license to mass produce
doses of the AstraZeneca
vaccine, and it had agreed
to actually export this
to the Covax initiative,
and Covax was, of
course, counting on India
to make good on these promises.
Going into 2021, the mood in
India was one of jubilation.
India was reporting less than 10,000 cases
or roughly around that level.
Prime Minister Modi went
before the World Economic Forum
in Davos, and actually said that India
had beaten the coronavirus.
Little did both scientists
and policy makers know
that a more potent strain
of the coronavirus,
what we initially knew
as B1617 was brewing
within the Indian population.
So in April, in the US,
there was this real shift
in vaccinations where, all of a sudden,
supply was getting a lot more plentiful,
and there was a real sense that, you know,
we're really going to
be turning this corner.
At that same time, we also
began to see, you know,
that there were people out
there who were not interested
in being vaccinated.
Covid-19 vaccines can help save lives,
but many people are still
hesitant to get that jab.
It wasn't that long ago that
all we were talking about
was how hard it is to get
a Covid-19 vaccination appointment.
Now, take a look around me.
See all these empty chairs.
If you're like 21 years
old, and you say to me,
"Should I get vaccinated?"
I go, "No."
Yeah, getting people truthful information
about the vaccines was one
of the most critical things
we could do.
Unfortunately, there are a
lot of mistruths out there.
More people are dying
from the Covid vaccine
than from Covid.
There has been people
who've long suspected
that there was some sort of an interface
between what's being
injected in these shots
and all of the 5G towers.
I think we didn't do a
good enough job, early on,
communicating to the public.
We didn't have public health agencies
speaking about the vaccine,
trying to encourage consumers
to go out and get vaccinated
when they could get access
to the vaccine, and that was a mistake.
We sort of ceded the
information marketplace
to people who were putting
out a countermessage.
One of the things that we began to notice
when we really began to look at
vaccination data in the U.S.
in detail, was that there was
this significant split
emerging, and so you can see
on this county-level map here
where red and orange places
have really low rates of vaccination.
If you take a look at these
places in orange and red,
like the Mountain West down
here in Louisiana, Arkansas,
and Mississippi, places
in Florida and Michigan,
a lot of those places are the same places
that have been very, very
hard hit by the Delta variant.
Levels of vaccine hesitancy
remained relatively high
in the U.S., but the
phenomenon starts to show up
in other countries, as well.
An example of that globally
is with China and Russia.
China and Russia, very
early on, made the decision
that they were going to start
administering their vaccines
well before they had been fully tested.
The lasting effect of that decision
is that it really shook
everyone's confidence
in those vaccines, both the
people in China and Russia,
and also the people who were contracted
to buy their vaccines.
You can see the result
particularly in Russia.
A lot of the Russian people
are still very suspicious
of the Russian Sputnik
vaccine in particular.
In some ways it's
unfortunate because, overall,
they're safe and effective vaccines,
just like a lot of the Western vaccines,
but these are the kinds of decisions
that public health officials have to make
in a tough situation, and
sometimes there's no right answer.
Meanwhile, another crisis is brewing,
the rise of a devastating new variant.
Delta really reared its head in India
around March, April 2021.
That was when we saw
the numbers increasing.
Everyone thought we were beyond
the worst of the coronavirus.
What officials in India called a tsunami
of coronavirus cases, nearly 1 million
in the last three days alone.
Now the Indian health care
system, on the best of days,
is inadequate.
When Delta started flaring up in India,
what we saw is that
hospitals were so overflowing
that even the richest
couldn't access health care.
We don't have anything available
and patients are dying.
Hospitals were running out of
basic supplies like oxygen.
We saw crematoriums overflowing.
It was a desperate situation in India.
With Delta ripping through its population,
India is forced to make a
decision with global consequences.
The Serum Institute of India ended up
having to redirect much of its supply
to its own domestic needs.
We saw India discontinue exports to Covax,
and that really meant
that African countries,
at the time, did not have
anywhere else to turn.
Midway through the year,
Covax has only distributed
88 million doses, far
short of its original goal
of 1.8 billion by the end of the year.
We did an analysis of the gap
between the wealthy countries
and the poorest countries
and their access to these
vaccines, and we found
that the wealthiest countries
were getting vaccinated
at a rate that was 25 times faster
than the poorest countries.
And the poorest countries,
they're still struggling
to get basic levels of vaccination
and the countries are suffering for it.
Every time vaccines came,
supplies would be over
in just a matter of hours.
I remember when I tried
to go get my first shot
for the AstraZeneca vaccine,
I waited a whole day
in a queue and I could not
get it, so I only managed
to get my first shot
after queuing for days.
It really showed how big that divide is.
The vaccine campaign in the United States
kind of hit its low point in July 2021,
and that is largely because
things were going really well
at that point.
It was summertime, we celebrated July 4th
as kind of like a turning point.
But very swiftly after that
came the Delta mutation.
The Delta mutation, the vaccine
is less effective against it.
It still keeps people out of the hospitals
and prevents a lot of deaths,
but people started getting
and spreading and transmitting
the virus more and more.
The Delta variant, in
fact, already sending
unvaccinated Americans to the
hospital in alarming numbers.
Our in-patient units are at capacity,
and so people have to either
get better enough to go home,
or if they succumb to their illnesses,
and die, that opens up a bed.
The Delta variant, because
it is so contagious,
does, unfortunately, a very
good job finding people
who haven't yet been vaccinated.
Nurses are not only tired,
but in short supply.
We have a very low vaccination
rate in our community
here in Idaho, and nobody's masked,
and people are like, "Yeah."
It's all open, it's all free."
And it's devastating to me.
Will the vaccine save them now?
No, but you could have done that before.
Soon after Delta's arrival in the U.S.,
evidence starts to emerge
that the vaccine's efficacy
is waning over time.
The problem is first identified in Israel,
one of the world's leaders
in vaccine administration
and data tracking.
You had Israel collecting
more systematic data,
and they were the first to pick that up.
CDC actually dismissed the Israeli data
when it first emerged in the summer.
CDC's probably going to do a
really good analysis of that
and tell us exactly how
many breakthrough infections
occurred six months later,
but it doesn't help inform
decisions that have to get
made in real time, like,
"Should we be administering boosters
to high-risk populations?"
The news is not as bleak in
other parts of the world.
India's infection rate,
having peaked in May,
continues to plummet as the
country's vaccination program
finally gathers steam.
Vaccinations increased
sevenfold from April to August.
In Brazil, whose anemic early campaign
cost hundreds of thousands of lives,
a stunning turnaround is underway.
In June, July, you really
started seeing more of a pickup
and in July that coincides
with when we started getting
more Pfizer shots at hand,
and when governments
started broadening groups
that were eligible for vaccine.
Brazil's rate of first doses administered
soon surpasses that of the U.S.
Relatively low levels of vaccine hesitancy
helped make this possible.
The country's world-class
national health care system
also plays a decisive role.
It would have been much, much worse
without this public health care
system, which is everywhere.
Brazil is a huge country.
They have more than 30,000
posts spread across the country
so you will see pictures
of health care workers
giving vaccines in canoes
in the Amazon, you know,
and it really is everywhere.
Yes, we took much longer than needed
to actually start
vaccinating, but right now,
it is a success story,
Brazil's vaccination campaign,
despite Bolsonaro railing
against vaccines to this day.
We are just now preaching to people
and we are praying for people.
Because there's no jab
and people have become, now
they are resorting to faith.
The vaccination rates
in Africa are still low.
Around November,
we were still looking at around 6%.
The coronavirus has taken
a huge economic toll
that has already taken
back some of the gains
that we achieved as far
as poverty reduction,
so there's a huge social
and financial toll
that this pandemic has put on Africa.
For many African governments,
it was a rude awakening
of being dependent on others for basics.
So we have seen several
African leaders announce plans
to set up vaccination plants.
South Africa, Senegal,
Rwanda, Uganda, Kenya,
all announced plans to either expand
or actually start new vaccination plants.
They want to be prepared
for the future so that,
in case of a, say another pandemic,
then you will not really be solely relying
on vaccines from outside.
It's been a rude
awakening for the Africans
to shape up for the future.
As 2021 comes to an end,
the threat of Covid-19
is far from extinguished.
Even as many countries have
achieved high vaccination rates,
others lag far behind, and a new variant
of unknown potency has started to spread.
Omicron is already labeled
a "variant of concern",
meaning it could be more transmissible
and possibly more virulent.
I think one of the challenges of dealing
with the SARS-CoV-2
virus is that, you know,
it always takes several weeks
to really get the answers
that you need.
I don't think we know
yet what the future is
with Omicron and hopefully
we will in the coming days
and weeks, but I think uncertainty
is probably the core
story of this pandemic,
and having to make decision after decision
without all of the
information that you need.
This pandemic has really
highlighted a lot of the problems
with the global public health system,
but I think it's also
important to take a step back
and look at what just happened.
A year after the first
shots went into arms,
8 billion shots have been administered.
That is a stunning number.
We have vaccine campaigns in
every country in the world.
That didn't happen with polio,
it didn't happen with a smallpox vaccine,
it didn't happen with, you
know, AIDS medications.
For all of those, it took decades.
How long this pandemic persists depends,
to the largest degree, on
how we use the knowledge
we've gained so far and the tools
that are becoming available
in terms of vaccines,
tests and treatments.
We could have this
pandemic well under control
and be coming out the other
side of it within six months,
or it could take over a year.
We've got to make sure that the
tools that we have available
are equitably distributed around the world
so that we can reduce the
risk of variant emergence
as we bring down the burden
of disease and, of course,
get economies functioning again.